Club Asian for serious readers
this weekend on book TV we bring you the
22nd annual Virginia festival of the
book we kick off our coverage with Bruce
Hillman author of the man who stalked
Einstein followed by author panels on
u.s. naval history the Civil War and
astronomy here's mr. Hillman on the life
of Nazi scientist Philippe Lonard
morning my name is Erich Ribbeck I'm a
former Charlotte civilian glad to be
back this year and I welcome everybody
on behalf of the Virginia Foundation for
the Humanities the producer of the
Virginia festival of the book I also
want to mention that we want to thank
the city of Charlottesville for
sponsoring the festival and providing
this wonderful venue this event is being
recorded for broadcast on
Charlottesville's own TV ten will be
available online at Charlottesville dark
slash TV ten also remembered when we get
to the Q&A later please raise your hand
I'll call on you and wait for the mic to
be handed to you also our friends at
book TV c-span are recording this to be
cable cast at a later date so look for
that
please remember to silence your
cellphone's if you are on Twitter you
can tweet at hashtag
VA book 2016 and remember that the
festival is free of charge not free of
cost so please remember to go online and
give back or pick up a giving envelope
from the information desk at the Omni
and support your festival please also
remember to fill out your program
evaluations these really are useful to
the people who put the festival together
and you can fill out a paper evaluation
before you leave or complete it online
at VA org slash survey do support
festival authors and our local
booksellers by purchasing a book today
and of course our author will be
available for book signing after the
program our program this morning is
titled modern science obsession paranoia
jealousy and Einstein
Bruce Hellman the author of the man
who's talked in Stein is a professor and
former chair of radiology at UVA he has
published a number of short stories and
literary journals and a book explaining
medical imaging for lay readers Einstein
is his first book of creative nonfiction
let's welcome Bruce Hillman thanks very
much
great to be here so with this whole
background how is it that you are now a
creative nonfiction writer yeah it's if
you look at the program I look quite a
lot different than the average
first-time writer I'm a little older and
hopefully I've learned that something in
the sixty-eight years that I've been
around I actually owe my writing career
- and who was someone who was an
associate dean at the University of
Virginia Medical School a woman named
Sharon Haas sir I thought Sharon might
be here today but I guess she's
elsewhere Sharon ran at just a - our
little program about writing as a
pastime for physicians and I had a spare
a couple of hours one day went down
participated in the very end there was
an exercise where they gave a sentence
and I was supposed to write all of us
were supposed to write a paragraph or
two of a story that would be based on
the sentence and I did that I turned it
in and about a week later I got a call
from Sharon and she said really liked
your paragraph I've been running a
critique group of about six or seven
women for a number of years here in
Charlottesville and we need a man
she wanted to know whether I wanted to
try out and so I wrote a story remember
the stories hmm I remember the stories
still called the lemon and they took me
in and I was rough made that but they
worked on me and they really made it not
only that I enjoyed creative writing
again hadn't hadn't done any for many
many years but that I learned so much
about what better writing was than I
could originally originally do and so I
owe this to them and and they still meet
I actually met with them a couple of
days ago when I returned to
Charlottesville this book and say why
this book why creative nonfiction I
actually was doing some lecturing out in
Australia and it turns out that it's a
lot cheaper Australia is about the most
expensive trip you can take from the
east coast of the United States it's
much much cheaper if you just keep going
around the world and there are all kinds
of rules that you have to follow but
they all involve long hauls and so my
wife and I went out to Perth and I
lecture little and I started writing a
novel and I wrote that novel just about
finished it by the time the 28 days of
going around the world had finished now
I didn't still haven't found an agent
for that novel and that novel remains
unpublished it's it's a medical murder
mystery that takes place out in Arizona
where I used to live but I realized when
somebody was interviewing me for my
class I I went to Princeton as an
undergraduate
somebody was writing my story for our
website and he I say well he's a writer
I asked for his advice he referred me to
an agent in Tucson and she said well I
don't do fiction anymore but if I like
your writing if you ever get a good
nonfiction idea I'd love to see it and
so I was still lecturing I went out to
Cambridge England and it's a long trip
too and I couldn't see just going for a
lecture and coming back so I spent a
week I got on a train it took me to
Aberdeen Scotland I got off the train
and I played a famous golf course called
Cruden day
and they hooked me up with a couple of
Canadians who told me this story about
their father their father had been a top
ranking General in the Canadian Army
during World War two and had been
attached to the nuclear testing at Alba
Alamogordo New Mexico and he'd been very
fit and had led a great life but all of
a sudden at age 70 he caught this severe
neurodegenerative disease died within a
year and they wanted to know whether the
testing had done it and so I asked him a
few questions they said protection no
our dad said there wasn't a protection
they gave him a chaise lounge they gave
him some dark glass and they said watch
this and so I thought well this might be
an interesting thing to write about and
I started researching it and it shows
you how luck can just come into play in
any phase of light certainly in science
which we might get into later on I was
going through some stuff related to
nuclear testing and I have no idea why I
was in the pile but there was this
article from a 1946 American Journal of
Renken ology crumpled yellow pages and I
read it and it was about a man named
Dilip Lonard an American Colonel hey
there Sharon I just mentioned you so at
any rate there was this man Philippe
Lonard he had been captured by the
Allies and an American colonel who was
going to be a neuro neuroradiologist
asked can I interview him about his
relationship with roentgen mill helm
Conrad rent can the discoverer of the
x-ray everybody thought except here this
man Philippe Leonard said it wasn't
renting at all roentgen was simply the
Midwife who had had the pleasure of
discovering the birth I am the true
mother of the x-ray so this man clearly
had some paranoid delusions but he also
had extraordinary narcissism he was such
an evil character I thought to myself
wow this is a great story roentgen and
Lonard so I called the agent and I wrote
up this you know two pager and she
she sort of flogged it around some
publishers and they said nobody's ever
heard of Rankin there's not an amazing
thing
talk about literacy so I I did a little
more research and I found that yeah but
Rankin had just been a sidelight at the
sidelight the guy he really had it out
for for many years had been Albert
Einstein so I called her back I said
anybody ever heard of Einstein and she'd
the so in the end there were a couple of
publishers who bid on it and and I wrote
the book great would you like to give us
a taste all right let me read a little
from chapter one Z Kyle the man's cry
found an echo in a thousand others on
the clear cool evening of May 11th 1933
the crowd repeated the familiar Nazi
greeting as ranks of university students
marched best encouraging frogs of
spectators into the vast expanse of
Berlin's opera square the students
arranged themselves around an enormous
blaze that the brown shirts of the Nazi
si had set and stoked into an inferno
earlier in the evening sparks shot into
the late spring night their explosive
barks all but drowned out by the cheers
of more than 40,000 onlookers young
faces reflected the heat of the bonfire
and their excitement at a signal the
front rows of students move forward
stooped to gather arms full of books and
toss them into the flames
they gave way to the students behind
them reciting as they did their
prescribed verses each had committed to
memory against class warfare and
materialism for the community of the
people in an idealistic way of life
against decadence and moral degeneracy
for decency and custom and family and
government the ritual was repeated until
the flames had consumed twenty five
thousand books among the dozens of
authors whose writings had been trucked
from libraries to opera square early in
the day we're socialists like Karl Marx
social activists like Helen Keller and
humanists like
Ernest Hemingway organizers also had
removed from library stacks every copy
they could find of the works of the
numbered Jewish scientists their
revolutionary discoveries had helped
elevate German science to the apotheosis
of world recognition under the new Nazi
regime they had fallen out of favor as
the flames snapped and flexed in the
wind and the logs feeling the blaze
settled into embers a lone figure limped
up several steps to a roughly
constructed platform fronting the square
the chief of Nazi propaganda
reichsminister Yosef giggles surveyed
his audience
his sweating lupine face gleamed in the
shining light when he sensed the crowds
anticipation as grown as taut as he
could bear he began to speak the age of
an overly refined Jewish intellectualism
has come to an end and the German
Revolution has made the road clear again
for the German character in the past 14
years comrades you have been forced in a
silent shame to suffer the humiliations
of the November Republic the libraries
became filled with trash and filth from
Jewish at-fault literature's he paused
to give the crowd space - roars
disapproval you do well in these
midnight hours to consign the unclean
spirit to the past to the flames the old
lies in the flames but the new will
arise from the flame of our hearts let
it be an oath too many flames piled to
the right and the nation and our leader
Adolf Hitler gerbils shot the Nazi
straight arm salute fingers extended
palm forward into the cool night air as
the deafening applause settled down a
group of students began to sing the
Horst Wessel song the anthem of the Nazi
Party the tune was picked up by other
students and soon the surrounding
thousands the celebration was just
beginning it would continue long into
the night so tell us a little more about
Philippe Lonard yo has anybody here ever
heard of Philippe Leonard yeah it's an
amazing you know there's a gentleman
extraordinary hardly anybody has ever
heard of this man
despite the fact that he was the Nobel
Prize winner for physics in 1905 he was
a man who was an arch experimentalist he
was very famous in his time he'd won the
Nobel Prize for his work with cathode
ray tubes he'd made a modification of
the cathode ray tube that perhaps rent
can it even use we don't know but might
have used that night that allowed him to
know about the X rays but he had some
problems this leonard fellow Einstein at
one point talks to a student about how
twisted Lonard seemed to him he did have
a severe narcissistic personality but
everything started out all right
Einstein was 17 years his junior they
had a very cordial if very peripatetic
correspondence at one point in time
Einstein had done some work with the
photoelectric effect which Lonard had
first described in fact Einstein's law
the photoelectric effect is what he was
awarded the Nobel Prize for not for
relativity at any rate though that began
to degenerate first because of this
student Jakob Johan Loeb one of Leonard
students who initially started out
thinking Lonard quite the fellow just as
Einstein did but over time realized that
he had some odd quirks he was a habitual
virtually difficult person who made his
students work on things they didn't even
believe in and such was the case with
love
and overtime things between Einstein and
Lonard disintegrated
at first it was mainly a scientific
difference as I said Lonard lunardon was
a an arch experimentalist Einstein of
course was the best-known ever
theoretician his theoretician Lonard
came to believe that the whole
theoretical physics mathematically
derived formula was a hoax that in fact
it was a Jewish hoax it was something
that that was a
had no rounding in real life and that
perhaps the the Jews who were the
foremost in this field didn't even
intend for it to be true that the whole
thing was Charlotte's Henry simply to
get jobs and to become famous and
popular and that did occur and we can
take up the story from there if you like
or you may have other questions so
things really fell apart beginning
towards the end of the first world war
first world war ended at the very end of
1918 and into 1919 when the Treaty of
Versailles was signed and Germany was
terribly penalized for having in in at
least in the belief of the Allies having
started the war the Treaty of Versailles
required the reparations of at that time
33 billion u.s. dollars which fabulous
amount of money
inflation was wildly rampant in Germany
over a period of months entire fortunes
were wiped out by inflation in months it
went from four to the dollar to over
billion marks to the dollar and so
people were suffering very severely
Lonard had terrible financial reversals
himself and his son had died during the
war very nerve an ER was a sickly child
it was a terrible disappointment to
Leonard who was an arch nationalist that
his son because of his illnesses had not
been able to participate in the war but
died of an ax fraud Extender OMA kidney
disease during it anyway Leonard was
easy pickings for the art for the
right-wingers this is the extreme right
wingers and the right wingers pathes I
had postulated it was a common
Shibboleth to believe that the Jews were
at fault that the Jews controlled the
International money markets and Lonard
picked up on this as well so over time
what became concerns that about science
became very personal Lonard personalized
his anger at the Jews in the form of
Einstein Einstein was the Jew he knew
the Jew who is becoming very popular in
German
he envied certainly was an important
factor as well but things broke down
between them and there was really no
correspondence following the last letter
that was sent prior to the war was
Einstein the the first scientist in
today's parlance we would call a rock
star okay so that's an interesting story
Einstein
I mentioned that Lonard in 1905 won the
Nobel Prize 1905 was not a bad year for
Einstein either it's been now known as
his miracle year we're out of nowhere
this patent clerk working in Bern who
had had had his PhD but really his first
degree was just to be able to teach
physics and mathematics he had earned
his PhD in 1905 after some difficulties
but out of nowhere he published these
five remarkable papers the three
best-known one the photoelectric effect
the law of the photoelectric effect
he explained Brownian motion which
became the foundation for colloidal
chemistry and he talked about time and
space the relationship between time and
space and mass and energy and his
special theory of relativity and
overnight he really started to climb the
ladder
he got himself an academic job which
incidentally paid well less than being a
patent clerk and burned and then started
to move around he went to Prague came
back to Zurich in 1914 Max Planck
personally recruited him to be the head
of the Kaiser Wilhelm Institute in
Berlin and professor at Berlin
University and with a lot of special
perks that most of the other professors
at the time didn't get linearity hated
this and when asked in fact originally
to allow him into the society the Kaiser
Wilhelm society by plunk and because he
knew that Lonard might be a problem here
the response was well simply because
simply because the goat resides in a
stable doesn't make him a thoroughbred
racehorse in 1919 important things
happen
Einstein had finished working on his
general theory of relativity in 1915 had
delivered a series of lectures that were
really quite convincing Germans were
coming over to this Jewish man's side he
was the term for people like Einstein
was he's underman
which of course was a euphemism for
something else but in 1915 he gave these
lectures he wrote up the general theory
he wrote a book that you and I can read
that I actually read in fact very short
called the theory of relativity
relativity the special and general
theories and he made some cosmological
predictions he predicted that first of
all light would Bend by gravity
so life from distant stars passing close
to our Sun would actually bend and
arrive at a different point than when
they were not aligned with our Sun he
also predicted how the course of mercury
would alter from Kepler's version Kepler
was the one who originally described the
course of the planets around the Sun
that it was supposed to be an even
source with every time the the point
closest to the Sun would be the same it
didn't occur that way the perihelion of
mercury as it's called was different on
every passage and Einstein explained by
a relativity how that occurred and
finally he predicted a shift in the
light spectrum the Sun the light in the
Sun versus the light as it arrived on
earth in 1919 one of those predictions
came true anybody know what happened in
1919 that allowed the proof this
gentleman what do you do for a living
sir there you go retired engineer yeah
good so others know as well good yes
there was an eclipse of the Sun in 1919
and
England sent out the Royal Society sent
out parties to the west coast of Africa
and to Brazil and they validated
Einstein's prediction in fact the Sun
did bend light from size from stars that
were adjacent to it and the crowds went
wild the newspapers said that everything
had been turned on its head that old
Newtonian physics no longer held and
that Einstein was this Rising Sun
literally rising star so overnight he
became famous and Lonard hated this he
thought well first of all he was an arch
Newtonian he was not about to give up on
on Newton and Kepler and and Copernicus
is Jettas German stars and here was this
man who was getting much more publicity
than he should he felt publicity he was
due of course and that it was just he
posed it instead that this was unworthy
of people in science and so that was
added to all the other of Einstein's
failings plus the fact that he was
growing increasingly radical and
increasingly anti-semitic just
continuing the background here what was
the working society of German scientists
okay so this was the reaction of Lonard
and maybe 10 or 12 other German
scientists they were going to take down
Einstein they were going to show him for
a fraud they were going to show the
theory of relativity is pure charlatan
really so Lonard
trying to stay in the background
nonetheless talk to the man who they
hired have been essentially hired to
take on this task a man named Paul
violin who called himself an engineer
but couldn't really produce any
credentials no offense sir but he was
more of a rabble rouser here AB aroused
the the extremist right-wing and he
agreed to develop a series of lectures
20 lectures 2 per night that would be
held over ten nights in a large Hall the
Berlin Philharmonic Hall over a period
of a month or two
and that was called the working society
to keep a I can't remember exactly works
as a society of German scientists for
the purity of science and the notion was
of this these lectures would just take
down Einstein and that would be that so
the very first pair of lectures the
Nazis but not just the Nazis believe it
or not there were more extremists than
that surrounded the hall they would sell
other they're selling their pamphlets
and pins and so forth
and Einstein attended to and he sat up
in the in the crowd and he listened to
this his stepdaughter Margo beside him
and made fun of the whole thing made
very light of it made jokes about what
was going on on the stage as as violin
first began and as he brought out a man
named Gehrke a scientist he wasn't as
amused as he appeared he thought about
it for a few days and he wrote an
article about what he called the
corporation or scientists incorporated
and he published it in one of the German
dailies the one that happened to be
Jewish owned and it raised an enormous
fuss because not only did he pick on the
people who had publicly participated and
were scheduled to participate he picked
on lay nard
he said Lonard is behind this with no
real proof to that effect and so it
raised an enormous ruckus Leonarda
basically accused einstein of slander
and eventually Einstein recanted but
only recanted through others voices his
friends voices he did not actually
recant any great extent
now what followed here you'd say well
okay big fuss over nothing but within
about a month and a half of that the
German scientists all of them the
physicists the chemists the
mathematicians were all to get together
for their very first meeting after the
first world war and it was an especially
important meeting because the German
scientists were banned from all of the
European meetings
there was enormous hard feelings that
dated back to certain episodes that
occurred in the second world in first
world war and so this meeting was really
all they had
and Einstein threw out a challenge he
said he was willing to debate anyone who
felt the theory of relativity was false
and of course nobody came forward
immediately but there was plotting in
the background and Lonard was the
ringleader they were originally going to
meet in Frankfurt and it turned out
there was a great deal of political
unrest in Frankfurt so they met in a
tiny bath town spa town called Baden
Alpine & Bad Nauheim
went on for 3-4 days it was all very
calm but on the final day that was when
the powers-that-be had scheduled the
debate where Einstein would stand the
test of the field everybody else in the
building and there were two burly guys
flanking the gates the physicists and
the chemists were the the sort of
special people who got in first and then
anybody else from the news the media and
violin was there as well
Paul violin and it was supposed to be
open discussion but in fact it very
quickly degenerated into sort of
name-calling between Leonard and
Einstein first some science then some
degeneration the name-calling finally
two children bickering over a toy is how
I would describe him at the end
Einstein nothing had been settled of
course at the end Einstein chased after
Lonard to the cloakroom Leonard said
it's too late he ran for the Train
and they never spoke personally ever
again and so it would have been fine I
think if it's except for bad now I maybe
the whole thing would have just been
buried under but from that moment on the
anti-semitism that Lane art had been
hiding came forward and there was
nothing but the two per day of
commentary about Einstein the failings
of his of his hypotheses and his
theories until Einstein was finally
chased from Germany in 1933
that didn't I'd steins personal life
also factored into the the criticism all
of this yeah absolutely
Einstein was so different from Lonard
Lonard was a very serious man and he as
I said he treated people poorly in
general but his underlings he treated
very poorly they were special case
Einstein on the other hand was an
extraordinary wit for instance the 1919
when the the proof the the solar eclipse
showed him to at least be right once on
one of his predictions he was asked by a
newspaper well can you explain for
people what relativity is all about and
the way he answered was well if you're
with a pretty girl an hour seems like a
second but if you're sitting on red-hot
cinder a second seems like an hour and
Einstein was quite the ladies man first
of all he was very attractive man before
the health care thing happened later in
his life the hair thing happened to me
too just in Reverse
but he was quite the ladies man and and
he loved women but in a very sexist way
of course I mean he once referred to
American husbands as the lap dogs of
their wives he referred to marriage as
the attempt to turn an incident into a
successful attempt to turn an incident
into a permanent relationship so and and
he was a philanderer I mean the fact is
that he cheated on his first wife my
Ravin Malaya Marik and he also cheated
on his second wife Ilsa Lowenthal
Einstein and and he told them about it
so even in that respect he wasn't the
kindest of men but mostly the world
adored him
he always had a interesting thing to say
he OE there are many many anecdotes I
mean I don't know how much time we have
it certainly there are many and so it's
from reading the book it seemed to me
that there was this issue of pure
thinking versus this kind of fuzzy
thinking and and at some point
Einstein's approach to science was to
relativity was was compared to moral
relativism yes the lack of absolutes yes
and that didn't sit well in that society
a Germanic society being what it was it
had nothing to do one had nothing to do
with the other
but the anti Einstein forces sort of
took advantage of this relativism that
was also beginning to occur in society
German society post-world War One the
very Prussian atmosphere even in Berlin
was held up during the day but at night
it was it was sort of times of gaiety
like the world was about to end and in
Prior perhaps it really was so
relativism had nothing to do with
relativity but again I mean they were
trying everything to take Einstein down
and that was the one thing I mean I
remember one quote particularly and
sure I'm going to get it exactly right
but Lonard compared in stein and by
Einstein he meant all of the theorists
to to the early 20th century painters
the Picasa is the other Kubis basically
he said well they couldn't paint so they
made up something they could paint and
Einstein and his group don't really
understand science so they made up
something that they could live with as
well it was that kind of bickering
Einstein tried to stay out of it
Einstein was as I said very popular for
a while in German society what took him
down was first of all the constant
hammering away by the anti Einstein
forces but he also was very different
than the rest of the German scientists
the German scientists were really very
very strongly nationalistic even the the
plots in the sommerfeld's the so-called
good guys the renkins they they were
very nationalistic following the war
Einstein was an internationalist he once
called he once called a nationalism the
measles of humanity so he was an
internationalist he was a pacifist he
was a it was very much against three
arming of Germany and so he slowly but
surely began the public opinion began to
turn from Turing on so Lonard was
supported at the highest levels of the
Nazi regime yes even to being able to
met with Hitler on it right one or more
occasions why were these issues of
science so important to the Nazis well
it meshed so well with their philosophy
their broader philosophy so if you can
read it pieces of mind Kampf which is I
mean real very hard to read frankly
quite frankly look they've matches
Einstein's ideas of culture and science
in Germany excuse me just a moment I
have to tell you I forgot to take some
medication I've got to do it okay so I'm
trying to get work it out in my pocket
while I continue talking
hey well I'm just gonna stand up for a
second you don't mind we didn't work
this out ahead of time at any rate so
Lenora developed a philosophy that he
called Deutsche physique or Aryan
physics and in 1933 just about the time
Hitler was consolidating his power
he'd been appointed to chest chancellor
the year before the burning of the rice
stat had occurred early on he'd managed
to get the part of the Parliament the
Reichstag to disband itself this is
quite a trick and the book goes into
some detail about how and why he did
that
it all fits so well deutsche physique
with with the Hitler philosophy and
deutsche physique basically posed that
there were differences in the way
different people thought about science
and that they were that this was related
to their ethnicity and their nationalism
and that really all great physics derive
from yet you guessed it aryan physics
excuse me a moment
arian physics and he went through some
of the others he said well Negro physics
that's not known yet Arabian physics
used to be important but that was
centuries ago and finally of course he
got to Jewish physics and he decided
that Jewish physics not only was a bad
thing for physics it was a bad thing for
the culture of Germany because Einsteins
made sense to other people younger
younger physicists in Germany who could
understand the mathematics Lonard was in
no position to judge the so-called
Jewish physics because he didn't have
the mathematical background he didn't
want the mathematical background he
thought the whole thing was a hoax but
what really got him wasn't just that
Einstein was getting more and more
prominent and that more and more people
were accepting his notion of physics it
was the Germans his people that were
coming over to Einstein's side and so he
hooked this book the introduction to
which was again I mean a rambling almost
unreadable cursing of Jews and and
theoretical physics and then three other
volumes that were a recanting of all the
lectures he had given over his lifetime
in physics by all accounts he was a
fabulous physicist in the physics
lecture Mileva Maric before she married
einstein actually took a semester in
heidelberg where at that time lane tarde
was doing a visiting professorship for a
year and she wrote Einstein about this
man he'd never heard of before and what
a fabulous lecture he gave over the
speed of electrons in in solution so
that's basically I mean the philosophy
the reason is the philosophy that Lonard
was touting for years and years had
crystallized become almost the Houmas
identical to Hitler's in the Nazis so
having thought about this a lot as you
have I'm sure is there any validity to
the concept that different ethnic groups
have different scientific mindsets
I think it's unquestionable then when
you talk about subjects like language or
culture that there are enormous
differences not to say one's better than
the other which of course he did in
science I like to think of science much
more as something that's really
international international in the sense
that and this is an example for instance
where let's say in Germany somebody
comes with a new new experimental
finding and that finding is sent by
journals
even then journals and and speaking
engagements around the world and in
Japan someone shows up and presents this
material and the Japanese who have been
working very hard on something but to no
avail
plug in this new piece of information
and suddenly the experiment works and we
all learn a little more about how a
universe operates do I think it's
possible that there are cultural
influences in science I guess I do but
much much less so and much less
deterministically than they are in in
cultural subjects that was quite the
opposite of what Lonard told us so the
Lonard
and his various colleagues came to a
position of power and that that and just
the the general situation with the jews
in germany right
forced a lot of scientists out right and
and so that created a shift in the
world's balance of scientific intellect
right so way from Germany to its enemies
what was result that's the subtitle how
Nazi scientists Philipp Lenard changed
the course of history Leonard did have
Hitler's ear now he was already quite
advanced in age at this point into 70s
but he had had the foresight to take on
and much younger acolyte Immanuel
johanna stark and johannes stark had
started out actually as a believer in
quantum theory but later joined the
experimentalist
I mean came to that basically ruined his
own career by complaining when he lost a
job to summer dews sommerfeld's
candidate and he wrote a long diatribe
that basically insulted physics and
physicists throughout europe and so when
other jobs came up he wasn't getting him
he'd apply they'd say thank you but no
thank you but suddenly when the Nazis
came to power Stark was in because he
had been helping Lonard all along he had
been an apologist in fact a supporter of
Leonard's claim to the discovery of the
X ray he had been a apologist and
supporter throughout the the anger that
occurred over Einstein as they said they
finally did manage to keep him from
returning to Germany probably saved his
life by keeping him from coming back at
a certain point and so stark and Lonard
suddenly were popular with the Nazis
they were empowered start gain two very
powerful physicians in German science
Leonore it had no pretensions to such
important positions he just wanted to
vanquish Einstein forever he wanted the
name to never be heard again he wanted
an Einstein's work not to be believed
again and when the law in 1933 the law
for the reconstruction of the German
civil service came about they pounced
that law was the law that said basically
if you were Jewish this is really
cutting through a lot to get to the
bottom line if you were Jewish or a
communist you couldn't work in the
German civil service now you know who
were civil servants all the professors
in all the universities and so it
created this situation where stark and
Lonard
were able to cleanse if you will the
German universities if you don't mind
I'll read a page or two actually of how
what went on here at 10:45 on the
morning of May 16th 1933 max plunk straw
of course being the most advanced of the
German scientist er and most regan
revered helped the dean of german
physicist from the backseat of his car
plonk stepped onto the curb of Berlin's
Vilhelm Strasse running alongside the
Chancellery despite a cold gusting wind
tickling his memory of what had been a
harsh winter plunk stood motionless for
a brief moment surveying his
surroundings the Chancellery was an
impressive rokuko' palace that had
served as a seed of German government
since 1875 plaque once thought his
graceful symmetry a harmonious example
of Prussian architecture that was no
longer the case not since the vie mark
government had rekted the crass modern
south wing it was a stained that was
impossible to ignore for better or worse
change was inevitable
as president of the Kaiser vilhelm
Society Germany's most prestigious
scientific organization plant had sought
the opportunity to speak with Adolf
Hitler the newly appointed Chancellor on
the current situation in future plans of
the society he had made certain to
arrive at the Chancellor's offices a few
minutes early so he could settle his
nerves and think about several issues
that had arisen since Hitler had taken
office chief among his concerns was a
new law this was the 1933 law that
mandated the dismissal of non-aryan
civil servants the word non-aryan was a
euphemism for Jewish since all faculty
and staff of German universities were
classified as civil servants the law
threatened the continued employment of
all Jewish professors indiscriminate
enforcement of the new law would result
in the dismissal of many of Germany's
elite scientists chemists and
mathematicians and irreparably hinder
the progress of German science for years
to come this would be plox only chance
to reason with Hitler he would need to
hit keep his wits about him if he were
to have any chance of getting through to
him
as a secretary assured him into Hitler's
office plunk considered how he might
effectively address the concerns in a
way that Hitler would understand he
decided to use as an example
Jewish colleague fritz haber anybody
know about Fritz Haber good the Nobel
laureate had recently resigned his
university position in protest of the
new law Habra was Jewish Harvey was a
national hero for his invention of
processes for producing poisonous gases
during the Great War without which
Germany would have lost from the start
Planck broached the subject delicately
but Hitler was immediately on the alert
I have nothing against Jews as such
Hitler said but all Jews are communists
and is the latter who are my enemies it
is against them that my fight is
directed there are different types of
Jews Blanc said both worthy and
worthless ones to humanity with old
families of the highest German culture
among the former he suggests that the
distinction should be made of the
various sorts that's not right a Jew is
a Jew Hitler objected all Jews stick
together like burrs when there is a Jew
all kinds of Jews gather right away it
should have been duty of the Jews
themselves to draw a dividing line
between the various types they did not
do this and that is why I must act
equally against all Jews plunks said
forcing worthy Jews to emigrate would be
equivalent to mutilating ourselves
outright because we die early need their
scientific work and their efforts would
otherwise accrue primarily to the
benefit of foreign countries the
Chancellor ignored the comment after an
uncomfortable minute Hitler said people
say I suffer occasionally from nervous
disability this is slander I have nerves
of steel as if to prove how sturdy he
was he began to bang his fists on his
knee and he spoke extremely fast beating
himself into a great fury plunk was left
with no choice other than terrain silent
and take his leave so it's exactly right
1,400 roughly 14
I'm sorry roughly 2,000 Jewish
scientists chemists mathematicians were
forced out of their jobs
that included 14 Nobel Prize winners by
the way and the ones that could get out
all went to places like the United
States and England and and Russia all
enemies of Germany in the Second World
War and at a very great effect so lots
of loathing politics
II go there but you never have had that
in science sense right it's not exactly
so this is why this is why I write this
kind of work it's very hard maybe this
is the exception I mean that you're here
to say you are an exception maybe you
could pick up a science book and read it
but very few people want to do that
anymore and I see this kind of work
putting science in the context of an
interesting story an instructive story
as a way to get people to actually be
interested in learning science and and
has it happened again well there's
enormous of course people are all very
familiar with the line that academic
academic politics are the most vicious
because there's so little at stake it
goes on and on my next book one that I
hope will be out this fall it's sort of
in the proof stage goes into again many
of the same themes about academic
politics and and how they bring down
even very talented individuals so no
it's certainly nothing novel it's just
on a much grander scale and you've had
some reactions to to this book that
really bolster your feelings about
making reading about science interesting
yeah I know you got one you wanted to
share this is it's basically this came
yesterday I hope I can find it very
quickly on my cell phone yeah so I have
some hobbies in addition to writing one
of which is playing golf and I played
down in Durham or used to play down in
Durham an awful lot I live in Wake
Forest North Carolina now
and one of my playing partners actually
bought a book this is why so nobody can
live off [ __ ] thinks they keep lending
it out you can't live on an income
because people actually buy and they
just give them to their friends at any
rate one friend that they gave it to
wrote back to say the following thanks
so much for sharing the Einstein book I
can probably I can hold on to it a bit
longer for Richard her husband to read
it to Richard's mother earned her PhD in
physics under Arnold Sommerfeld one of
the white Jews now we didn't get into
white Jews but white Jews were people
who weren't Jewish but who believed in
Einstein and sympathized with the
theoretical physics so at any rate in
physics under artists Sommerfeld one of
the white Jews by some error
she and Edward Teller father of the
hydrogen bomb were signed the same
dissertation topic to solve teller
solution was more complete and as his
solution is the one cited now I have
never seen dr. Strangelove but I am
hoping to stream it it sparks in here
about how teller is thought to be the
model for the mad scientist in dr.
Strangelove when Richard's parents
emigrated to the u.s. and 1937 his
mother had a job at Duke under heythis
phoner the famous Soames physicist who
had been her lab instructor and yet
again
Hertha later married james franck many
women have recognized the name james
franck james franck of the manhattan
project in the Frank Frank report which
basically recommended not dropping the
atomic bomb
so she admitted she married Frank after
his wife died this is Richard's mother
Richard's parents left Durham because
his father an MD PhD was in unable to
get a medical license in North Carolina
that's a separate story how the u.s.
treated immigrant Jews are allowed
whether they allowed them even to
emigrate his mom died when he was 16 he
thinks she was perfectly happy I'm not
so sure
unless she felt she's seen too much with
the war in loss of the world she knew
and just wanted to hide away so you
could never have guessed how exciting
Bruce's book would be to us
out of nowhere this is why certainly
it's why I write I suspect this why most
people write in publish because you
don't know who's out there and
occasionally you can actually change
thought or change lives and and this was
just wonderful to receive so thank you
for allowing me to read that thanks so
we have time for some questions from the
audience if there are any please raise
your hand I'll call on you and then wait
for our volunteer with the mic and this
gentleman over here research process
that you went through for this book you
know do you speak German did you travel
to Germany etc yeah it's this I speak a
little German but the fact is first many
of Einstein's papers have been translate
about half of his papers have been
translated as the enormous project
international project to do so but if
you look at the book its cover and you
can tell a lot my cover sometimes there
are two German co-authors one is
Beardsley Birgit hurdled Wagner who's
also a radiologist and a physician in
Germany in Munich and her husband Bern
fagner originally a historian but now in
business and they're good friends Birgit
was a fellow under me when I was running
a large clinical trials operation and
she came over as a fellow for two months
and we've been friends ever since and so
they did translating and editing and a
lot of other things as part of their
authorship anybody else this lady over
here wait for the mic please
could you tell us a little bit about
Renkin in Lennar yeah that's that's a
really interesting story is chapter six
in the book and what happened was Lonard
as I mentioned had been working a
younger man than Renkin had been working
in the area of cathode rays and he
almost certainly had seen signs of the
x-ray but like so many people in science
they saw what they expected to see they
didn't take and this is a big theme in
my next book called a plague on all our
houses everybody sees what they expect
to see except the unusual individual who
sees something new and makes the
discovery and Leonard didn't do that so
when Redken on November 8 1895 did see
and recognize that it wasn't the cathode
rays that was making his cardboard
covered with platinocyanide light up he
missed an enormous opportunity he was
very very resentful and when he won the
Nobel Prize in 1905 this is lain hard
Renkin won the very first one in 1901
which Leonard thought was just very
unfair that at the very least they both
should have been named but when Lonard
finally won in 1905 he really took down
roentgen heart he said again that this
was this was not the man who should be
credited with the discovery of the X ray
that it was really he when roentgen
wrote his will his last will he ordered
all of his papers be burnt except a
letter he had received from Lonard many
years earlier crediting him with the
discovery of the X ray and when the
Nazis came to power the folks in virtus
burg photocopied it primitive
photocopying and they had many copies
spread around Germany and elsewhere in
Europe and even to Japan so that Lonard
would never be able to have the sole
copy of that letter and destroy it or
Lonard x' forces the sympathizers so
it's a great story too and it's actually
one of my favorite chapters in the
other questions fascinating book thank
you I don't believe in glib comparisons
but it makes me very concerned when
there's a distrust of science by a
society and and a slander of it mm-hmm
and it seems currently in our country
that certain people say that there's a
real America and another America and
that they wouldn't want a Harvard
professor helping them if their car
broke down certain political certain
politicians said that and and that
global warming is doesn't climate
changes are hoaxes because it feeds so
many salaries what can we do now to help
support our scientists to support our
intellectual community no I think first
you can become scientifically literate
yourself I mean the level of literacy in
general in this country is is ferry port
and scientific literacy is much worse
than that
and so I mean before you can start to
debate or challenge the naysayers you
really have to understand a little of
the science yourself or at least
understand at a level where you can
communicate it and work with others who
also can who think similarly and who can
communicate it as well I think that's
the biggest sleep to be perfectly honest
in in combating so that so that ordinary
folk like you and me we can understand
it and we can and we can combat it
well well good these gentlemen are
Facebook
I sign itself greatly highly regarded
for his theoretical contributions but he
grew up in a family of what we today
would call probably electrical engineers
they've they produce power they made
motors yep and he probably did well as a
patent clerk because he understood the
practical aspects as well of the
technology at age did this facet of his
background enter into his interactions
with the rest of the community so I have
no doubt it did but I think really the
patent clerk think the reason he was a
patent clerk was he couldn't get a job
in a university even though that the
university job would pay much less he
had married married by that point in
time they'd actually had a girl nameless
Earl but nobody knows what happened to
Lazaro whether she died young or whether
she was they she was born out of wedlock
back in Serbia where Marik had gone to
give birth and so nobody nobody would
even know about Cyril except it was
found in one of Einstein's letters many
years after his death so his family is
another story they left Germany and went
to Italy and as you say formed an
engineering firm that was fairly
successful at least for a while
Einstein gave up his German citizenship
at that point in time and finished high
school in Switzerland and then of course
got all his education in Switzerland -
it's impossible to say he was not he was
never a student of engineering as I said
he was a student of teaching math and
physics Merrick was also a student of
teaching math and physics but she never
passed her final exams so she never got
her degree from the Zurich Polytechnic
thank you very much I've enjoyed this
immensely thanks to Bruce Hillman so a
few closing announcements thank you for
coming as well please complete the
evaluation forms as opposed to a certain
University you've heard of there is no
pressure to be nice on the evaluation
forms and I wasn't talking about UVA and
and you have an opportunity now to my
book to have it signed and to meet our
author thanks again